- [Mark] Okay. All right, J.
- Yes.
- [Mark] J, where'd you grow up?
Where're you from originally?
- [J] Milwaukee, Wisconsin.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
when you were young?
- [J] Yeah, they were both there.
My dad eventually left
when I was about 12.
- [Mark] And how would you
describe your childhood?
- It was tumultuous.
Very, I don't know,
dysfunctional and my parents
were both kind of like
absent most of the time.
Like, I was just kind of on my own, really
for the most part, so.
- [Mark] No abuse or anything like that?
- Yeah, there was a lot
of verbal, some physical.
They were both alcoholics, so yeah.
- [Mark] You had siblings?
- Yes. Two older sisters, indeed.
- [Mark] And you, you finished school?
- I did finish high school, yeah.
- [Mark] So what'd you do after that?
- Not much. I had drank for a
few years and then I ended up
just getting on a Greyhound and
coming out to San Francisco.
- [Mark] So it's been,
you've been out here since?
- 2000, 2002. Yeah.
- [Mark] And what did
you do when you got here?
- Well, I continued to drink
for a little while and I moved
out here with my best friend at the time
and she ended up going into treatment
and I kind of just
graduated into narcotics
and basically just, you know,
partying and running
around the Tenderloin.
- [Mark] And what is your,
what is your drug now?
- My drug now? Fentanyl and crack cocaine.
- [Mark] And you're, you're living where?
- In a hotel on Lombard, with my friend.
- [Mark] So you're supporting
yourself the way a lot
of the other girls will
support themselves here?
I'm assuming.
- Well, I actually will
try to do any hustle to
avoid actually doing any sex work
but I do a lot of delivery
for methamphetamine.
And then I'm also a doctor,
which is I assist people
in injecting drugs safely.
- [Mark] Is that right?
- Yes, I do it.
They, you know, or they
know I'm responsible
for them being able to get high.
So they pretty much take
care of me pretty well.
So, it works out good.
Yeah.
- [Mark] Do you still have
contact with your family?
- I do. I do, yeah.
- [Mark] And they know what you're doing
or where you're at?
- Yeah, I'm pretty open and honest
about everything, so yeah, they know.
- [Mark] What's their reaction?
- They worry a lot.
Try to encourage me to come home.
I don't know, they just yeah,
I cause them a lot of worry.
Yeah, unfortunately.
I try to reassure them that,
I'm a lot safer than a
lot of people, I think.
I don't do anything to reckless
or I don't put myself in
any compromising situations
as long as I can help it.
Yeah. I don't know.
- [Mark] And drug use for
you started at what age?
Before you came out to San Francisco?
- Yeah, I was 16 when I first
started doing narcotics.
- [Mark] Who introduced you to them?
- My dad always had pills and stuff around
and I just knew it was known
that he like, you know,
he was a pill popper.
So, you know, like I would
eventually start stealing them
from him until he started
giving them to me.
- [Mark] And your
parents are both addicts?
- Yes.
- [Mark] And are they still using today?
- My mom isn't. My dad is.
- [Mark] And looking back at
your life, do you have regrets?
Any decisions you made
that you wish you hadn't
or anything like that?
- Yeah, definitely.
I regret not being more present
for my nieces and nephews and growing up.
I regret not, I don't know
just taking more opportunities
and just kind of going
with my gut more instead of
denying myself all the time
and talking myself out
of things a lot. Yeah.
- [Mark] Have you been in love before?
- Yeah. Yes, I have.
- [Mark] Can you tell me about that?
- Oh, it's (laughing) the most amazing,
beautiful, indescribable
experience I've ever had
and also the most devastating and painful.
- [Mark] What was that,
just the breakup or?
- I think the breakup was a relief.
That was a better part,
I think, towards the end,
but no just having to face yourself
and having to face all
the ugly things, you know,
about yourself as well
as the beautiful things.
And, also having to accept
that about the person you love
and having to remember in
the end that you're both
just human beings, you know?
And we both make mistakes
and nothing is forever and
nobody's perfect, you know?
- [Mark] What's the most
important lesson you've learned?
- [J] That only I am in control of
whether I'm, you know,
in pain or feel good
or only I'm in control of being hurt
and dealing with some negativity.
I only let,
I only allow,
that's my responsibility
of what goes on in my life
and what I'm affected by
and what I choose to be a part of
and what I let happen to me.
It was under my control only, so yeah.
- [Mark] Do you feel like
the fact that your parents,
like you grew up with
parents that were addicts,
may have opened up the door
for you to do the same?
I mean, it sounds like you're raiding
your dad's pills early.
- [J] Yeah.
It definitely made it easier,
more prevalent, I think.
I would've probably either
anyway, anyway I would've,
you know, became an
addict myself regardless.
- [Mark] Yeah.
And living this life where,
you're on the Tenderloin and there's lots
of drugs and crime and prostitution
and all that kind of stuff
going on all around you.
Is that, does that get depressing for you?
Does it get on your nerves after a while?
- Extremely, yeah.
It's a small, small little area with
a large amount of negative,
concentrated negative energy
so it's constantly overwhelming and it's-
- [Mark] You get depressed sometimes?
- All the time, yeah.
I don't know, I remain disconnected
as much as possible and try to be
not present as much as possible, so.
- [Mark] Yeah. What do
you think the solution
might be for you?
- Discipline.
I don't know.
- [Mark] Do you think
loving yourself could be
a part of the solution?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Sometimes the shame that you feel
and stuff like that
gets, you know, sabotage,
you know it just creates self-sabotages.
- It makes it hard to have a,
somewhat normal, functional
human interaction or,
you know, it makes interpersonal
relationships difficult,
for sure.
- [Mark] And do you have kids?
- No, I don't.
- [Mark] I thought maybe
you were transgender
when I first met you because-
- I am.
- [Mark] You are? You are?
- [Mark] Oh, I didn't know.
I was always wondering.
I thought maybe you might be.
- Yeah, I am.
- [Mark] Oh, you are?
You had me fooled.
- God's got a weird sense of
humor, I suppose, I guess.
- [Mark] And was that part of
the problem with your family?
- No.
- [Mark] Did they take it well?
- Yeah, surprisingly. I
was really lucky, yeah.
Compared to most people so.
Pretty supportive family and yeah.
- [Mark] That's great.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And being a transgender woman,
that makes it tougher out here, now?
- I don't feel like anything's
more difficult or anything
is, you know, harder than
it is for anybody else.
You know, I don't buy
into that whole, you know?
- [Mark] You don't buy into it?
- I don't, I don't.
I feel like, you know,
it's just, you know, a different scenario,
different details, Same (beep), you know?
- [Mark] What was the
best part of your life?
Best memories? Best time?
- Good question.
Probably the three years I was married.
To my husband Isaac, yeah.
Best time of my life.
- [Mark] How many years ago was that?
- Six.
- [Mark] And how did that fall apart?
- He was a really paranoid schizophrenic
and we were taking a lot
of stimulants as well,
so that made it a million times worse.
So he ended up taking his own life.
- [Mark] Oh, he did?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I'm sorry.
- It's okay. It's not your fault.
It's part of life.
Death is a part of life.
- [Mark] What do you look
forward to for your future?
Do you have hopes of doing anything?
- Backpacking through
Europe, studying history.
- [Mark] History, yeah.
- [J] Yeah. That's my skeleton plan.
- [Mark] That's great.
- Yeah. I'm excited.
I'm looking forward to it.
- [Mark] Cool. Well J, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- [J] Yeah.
- [Mark] I wish you the best of luck
and hope you make it to Europe.
- [J] Thank you.
- [Mark] All right. Thank you.
- [J] Thanks.